ma première question savez toussaint
pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous a décidé à
refaire le sourd sur la scène on se
l'est fait offrir et on s'est réuni pour
ne trouver aucune bonne raison pour
refuser on avait tous le goût de se
reformer de chanter live avec des vrais
musiciens pour une fois sur une scène
devant des milliers de personnes
c'est un matelot souligné gilot mais
c'est ça moi je parlerais de nos scènes
souciant mais maintenant qu'on en
réalise
oui on réalise l'ampleur de la tâche
parce que chanter pendant 80 minutes ça
va être ça va être quelque chose d'assez
exigeant mais très bonne affaire comment
se prépare 90 minutes justement c'est
bon ça demande la préparation qu'est ce
que vous faites on commence par là et là
je parle de quelque chose qu'on a fait
hier quelques on peut même dire quelques
mois maintenant on commence par
réécouter et revoir bain des enfants
qu'on a fait des trucs qu'on avait
oublié des trucs qu'on trouvait le von
arx faire des trucs qui étaient
évitables
parce que des choses ben oui c'est sûr
pour chanter ça puis on met tout ça
ensemble on se rend compte que
finalement le 90 minutes on est capable
de avec deux pièces instrumentales de 15
minutes on est capable d'aller chercher
les golfeurs et d'interviews j'utilise à
la pause on fait un croyant et plus on
fait quoi là au complet puis on joue de
la flûte
il sait ça draine un bon numéro
il le rappelle c'est une chanson qu'on a
déjà chanté dans ce spectacle fait que
ça fait 90 minutes vous allez gâter
votre public clairement surviendront
mais on a quand même le souci de faire
un spectacle aux gens qui ne nous
connaissent pas c'est pas juste un
spectacle pour les vieux fans
nouveaux fans de la rb au lac ont chanté
trois chansons c'est donc non nécessaire
ce souci là donc on notera comme il doit
faire chaud in english is because we
mais vérifie que je maîtrise mon mari je
sais quoi c'est le monde tournée
mondiale nous oui c'est clairement fait
chaud la presse a en fait comme un jean
de lier des brokers de partout dans le
monde qui viennent vegas
je mélange est mon tournoi d'évoluer
sous peu mais ils viennent nous voir
puis à votre choix parmi trois ans de
famille tout ça va être cool je suis
vraiment des voix mais pour les fans les
vrais de la première heure qu'est ce
qu'on mange ce qui se concluront sortir
de l'hôpital ou de la maison de retraite
est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir compter leçon
des succès mais qui ont fait qui ont
fait votre autonomie est ce qu'il ya
vraiment des versions non toutes les
chansons que les gens préfèrent le désir
de pouponner chanter en choeur on veut
les contrats dire de la soupe soyons
francs ont fait 90 minutes 80 ou 90
minutes de show
malheureusement ne même pas le choix de
les mettre en ce moment les femmes 80
minutes ceci est pas d'applaudissements
c'est ce quelque chose si tu votes
énuméré les tournois quand on fait pas
puisque dont tu connais pas le titre ça
fait c'est cela qu'on fait pas les
autres on les fait toutes les autres
toutes les autres dans les faits on
tient spécifié que ce mec a une certaine
fréquence qu'ils soient émises sur le
site du quartier des spectacles
et puis donc le pont champlain était
sécurisé et l'échangeur turcot et les
jantes saint lambert on s'excuse à
l'avant ça se peut qu'elles vont
résister à la voix de qui on va les
faire des tests en du matin des sons qui
fait fuir les gens mais qui attirent les
chiens
exactement vraiment après un spectacle
vaut selon moi il marque à 5 ou 6 mai le
chien s'était vidée chier les moufettes
plus des râteaux l'année prochaine mais
sinon après ça qu'est ce qui se passe
est ce que c'est le premier spectacle
d'une longue suite suite à venir non
c'est toujours comme une fois par quatre
nous sommes à la fois quant à notre âge
là on est bien content de réussir un
coup
le prochain coup viendra qu'à push rod
établi moi je fais pas de promesses des
deux fois quatre fois c'est une fois
mais ça ça nous arrive souvent qu on
fait souvent des offres tout car le bye
bye
là ça tombe et que les spectacles cet
été on était tous disponibles ce qui est
38 c'est toujours son armée aux arv et
on a un système toujours communautaire
donc ce n'est pas quelque chose ou on
peut déléguer du travail j'ai écris moi
des textes préparés par mois soit
s'apprendre disponibilité totale des
quatre membres et c'est pour ça que on
ne voit pas assez souvent peut-être mais
je sais qu'on corps dès ce soir le mois
de juillet n'est disponible
j'aimerais bien on verra l'avenir
l'avenir le dira mais en théorie on
n'est pas disponible pendant un but
parce qu'il ya tout le monde en parle
qu'il commence industrie parce que
parfait il faut que nos quatre membres
soient disponibles en même temps chacun
pour avoir l'approbation le son et la
vidéo